you
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wiltshire host and our guest is
Louisa Lombard an assistant professor of
anthropology at Yale University she is a
cultural anthropologist who studies
African borderland areas where the state
is largely absent and a range of actors
govern her research locales primarily
the remote and little populated eastern
reaches of the Central African Republic
are further marked by violent histories
that continue into the present professor
lumbars main fieldwork interlocutors are
among the region's men in arms such as
anti-poaching guards and rebels today we
talk with Professor Lombard about her
recently published paper on violence
popular punishment and the war in the
Central African Republic welcome
professor Lombard thanks it's great to
be here so let's begin with an overview
of your paper tell us about it so
there's been a war on going in the
Central African Republic for the past
couple of years and a lot of people both
in the Central African Republic and
Beyond have been surprised by how
quickly the violence spread and came to
involve so much of the population a
range of different explanations have
been brought for us as to how this
happened politicians for instance the
president of the country has argued that
this is a case of manipulation that
politico-military entrepreneurs are
manipulating people into fighting into
perpetuating the war and in this paper
we argue that although those factors are
indeed quite important they miss
something really important as well and
that is the important place of violent
popular punishment in the country even
prior to the war and we argue that you
know war war is not a complete break
from the past it doesn't reflect a total
new situation it reflects rather the
continuation the transformation of
existing social practices so we try
to explain a little bit about how this
context of popular punishment developed
in the Central African Republic both
through the colonial period into the
independent era and as the country has
really seen its economic situation be
plummet and be eviscerated and a
widespread feeling of insecurity has
come to dominate people's lives and in
that context of insecurity and of even a
kind of pervasive enemy by which I mean
the situation in which people feel like
norms existing norms no longer really no
longer really help them understand their
lives and no longer really serve to
control the kinds of threats that they
feel like they face in that kind of
context popular punishment became quite
widespread and often entailed quite a
bit of violence as well okay what do you
mean by popular punishment that's an
excellent question so when we and I
should say that this is an article that
I co-authored with a central african
colleague sylvan batanga kinsey so when
we're using this term popular punishment
we're referring to things that other
scholars have referred to as popular
justice kind of vigilantism people for
instance when there's a suspected thief
who is apprehended and that thief is
beaten by a crowd to try to you know
show him that this is not something that
he should be doing and the reason that
we use the term popular punishment is
because we think that it's more
analytically precise the term justice if
we're referring to popular justice it
implies that this is something that
people feel is you know the ideal way
that a problem should be resolved and
what we see instead is not people are
very ambivalent about this popular
punishment they see it as necessary
given the grave threats that they face
but they see it as very very far from
ideal and we wanted to capture that that
people are talking about the need to
punish those the the people who are
bringing the threats into their lives
but that that is not exactly the same
thing as justice right so rather than
the police handling the problem people
are dealing with the situation
themselves yes and sometimes the police
sometimes people will hire individual
members of the police or the gendarmerie
to come and help them in this regard but
they're doing that the the the police
officers are then acting in there a kind
of private capacity and often will
participate in the violence themselves
and why would that happen versus the
police having a role in arresting the
thief and bringing them to jail well the
police you know our perennial II
under-resourced they don't really have
the capacity to deal with these kinds of
situations themselves and for that
matter they're often participating in
these kinds of violent punishments
themselves and they see it as necessary
also I mean one of our during one of our
interviews were with a gendarme who in
the middle of the night I noticed that
somebody was trying to break into his
house so he went and found the person
and began beating the person the
commotion drew other people from his
neighborhood who came in and started
beating the person as well they ended up
beating the man to within just an inch
of his life and at that point the
gendarme thought well maybe this wasn't
the right way to deal with this and they
managed to stop the beating and bring
the man to the hospital but he died
shortly thereafter and that John darme
said look the Jean de Marie is corrupt
everybody is corrupt and so we have to
take matters into our own hands right
you would think though that with that
level of punishment no one no crimes
would be committed but one would hope
but that's always the you know I mean we
see this elsewhere as well that the the
deterrent factor that is hoped for in
punishment for crimes does not always
work in the ways that we were would like
I mean of course capital punishment is a
perfect example of that you know what
led you to do this kind of work how did
you find yourself in central Africa
well I that's a long story at this point
but while I was an undergraduate it was
close to when I was graduating and I
went to a talk by somebody about his
research in the Central African Republic
and I but here I am and I've been
studying Africa for all this time and
here's a country that I've barely even
heard of how is this possible I want to
know more and so I got to know that man
and ended up working for him he was
became the managing director of a
research institute called the small arms
survey and I went back to went to the
country a number of times working for
them doing research on the social
impacts of having guns pretty widespread
in the society now that was before the
war broke out or just about during yes
so I should clarify a little bit there
there's been a lot of conflict in the
Central African Republic over the last
mmm 20 years or so I it's intermittent
it'll happen in different parts of the
country at different times it's only in
the last couple of years that we've seen
a real qualitative shift and it's become
a situation that I would describe as war
and who is the war between I mean is it
more political base more religious based
of combination so that's an excellent
question if you read newspaper articles
about what's going on in the Central
African Republic they'll often say that
there are two main groups that there is
the seleka rebel alliance and that
there's the anti-balaka rebel group the
problem with that way of thinking about
what's going on in the country is that
having these the these two names for the
different the opposing sides masks the
fact that what we have here is not two
groups with a kind of organized
hierarchy and structures of command and
objectives and all of that instead we
have two very diffuse processes of
violent mobilization that are in many
cases happening on a kind of village
basis and so it's a much more diffuse
and widespread process of mobilization
than a lot of the more journalistic
accounts might lead you to believe
now this is one of the reasons why it's
been so hard to draw the fighting to an
end it's because there aren't two people
you know one person on each side who you
can have sit down together and talk
through a peace process and then they
tell their subordinates and their
subordinates tell their subordinates now
it's time to stop instead again this is
a much more non centralized kind of war
in which people are fighting over things
that in many cases are reflect sort of
long-standing localized tensions more
than they do any kind of grand political
objective and how how large of an area
are we talking about and how many people
are involved well it's that's a
difficult question for one thing just
because it's it's very difficult to
obtain information about what's going on
in areas outside of the capital at this
point things have been calming down the
UN just deployed a peacekeeping force to
the Central African Republic just two
days ago so there so the violence is at
a lower point at this point but it has
involved I would say I you know the
southwestern part of the country the
northwestern part of the country the
northeastern part of the country really
the only area that has been largely
spared as the southeastern corner of the
country which is just very hard to get
to and has its own dynamics of conflict
it's one of the areas where the Lord's
Resistance Army is believed to be
hanging out so okay you know I'm curious
about you know how the methodology to
write the article you know how did you
do it I mean it seems like it would be
somewhat difficult to get all of the
information you need based on what
you've said so how did you go about
writing it well how did we go about
writing it or how did we go about doing
the research research so I'm an
anthropologist so I do ethnographic
field research and that involves a lot
of you know deep hanging out getting to
know people spending time with them
observing participating in their lives
and then also doing interviews and
trying to find out
we're what the sources of social tension
are and this article is really the
product of a very long engagement with
the Central African Republic howland so
I've been going there since 2003 so over
10 years at this point and I wanted to
you know I felt like a lot of the people
who were trying to explain what was
going on in the in the war over the last
two years we're acting as if prior to
the outbreak of war in 2012 there had
been a kind of peaceful baseline and so
I wanted to draw attention to the fact
that I had observed a lot of violence
over the time over my decade of of
getting to know people in the country
and that this is something that I think
is troubling and needs to be addressed
in spending so much time there were you
ever fearful for your own life as a
woman and as a white woman you know
that's a question that I get asked a lot
the short answer is no I was not the
longer answer is that I through the
years I've built up a network of people
I trust and I ask them I ask them what
is it's safe for me to do what I should
avoid doing what's going to arouse
suspicions and I listen to them and I
follow their advice and so if somebody
who you know whose hospitality I would
be relying on says no don't come don't
come here right now you know don't come
to this town then I listen to them and I
don't go there and I'll go somewhere
else because I'm really interested in
trying to better understand dynamics of
conflict how they work how it happens
all of these kinds of things but I'm not
interested in getting myself into
situations that I can't get myself out
of and i think that my method you know
the ethnographic method in some senses
is helpful in this regard because i know
that in order to do effective research i
have to be able to rely on trust from my
interlocutors and if i'm going into a
situation where tensions are just too
high then i'm not going to be able to do
that anyway so better to you know better
to save
energies for places where I can do my
research more effectively okay let's
talk about some of your findings in your
paper tell us about you know some of the
conclusions that you come to so I in the
conclusion of the paper I we argue that
again this is coming out of my
experience both doing research in the
country and then also providing
briefings and other kinds of things for
different members of international
agencies that are trying to stop the
violence or and build peace in the
country you know and those types of
organizations they tend to focus on
institutions they tend to focus on the
formal state structures which in the
Central African Republic are extremely
weak so that's an important goal in
certain respects but at the same time I
think that in order to prevent real
outbreaks of violence in the country in
the future we need to pay greater
attention also to the place of violence
and even vengeance and popular
punishment in central Africans sort of
conceptions of how to deal with threats
that they face in their midst because
this situation a very pervasive
insecurity that is probably not going to
end anytime soon so there needs to be
some kind of reckoning as to you know
reckoning for central Africans among
central Africans as to the place of
popular punishment and vengeance in
dealing with those kinds of problems so
I mean how would you go about changing
that it seems like it's part of the
culture at this point having having gone
on for so many years popular punishment
how do you turn that around and how do
you fix something like that well the
interesting thing about culture is that
you can have long established patterns
and there there is always the
possibility of change and change is
continual as well and I think that you
know for if there if if there were some
kind of a
a really widespread localized sort of
forum for talking about the sources of
insecurity and trying to deal with the
sources of insecurity that that central
Africans feel in some kind of effective
way then that might be a way to diminish
the importance of a popular punishment
you know doing that in concert with
trying to support the state security
sector in in ways that will help them to
be more accountable to people and and
more effective in dealing with and the
threats that people feel like they are
facing which primarily have to do with
theft and witchcraft really yeah I was
going to say is you know food an issue
or you know lack of jobs that kind of
thing but that's absolutely an issue was
about but it all happens in a context in
which you know the forces of the occults
the kind of invisible world are seen as
playing a really important role in
people's lives and a really dangerous
role in people's lives that is
fascinating I had no idea that that was
an element so tell us a little bit more
about that historically has that been
the case there yes that has been it has
historically been the case there I mean
it's always talking about witchcraft in
Africa is a really fraud thing to do
because when we hear the word witchcraft
we think you know women wearing black
pointy hats and Halloween and all of
that kind of stuff the Western group we
assume that that's what what we're
dealing with in Africa is well and
instead it's more it more has to do with
the fact that people understand there to
be a visible world that we can see and
observe and then also an invisible world
where there are forces that we can't
control and that those invisible world
forces are also having a really
important impact on the ways that are
the sort of vicissitudes of our lives
and are there some people who are said
to have some control over that other
world yes there are people were referred
to in Ganga the traditional healers
who have a lot of knowledge of the
invisible world and some power to manage
it but one of the reasons why people
feel like there's such pervasive and
security now is that the forms of
witchcraft these kind of occult forces
that are part of people's lives have
really transformed and become ever more
powerful surpassing these in ganga's
capacity to deal with it Wow very
interesting well I could talk to you all
day about that but final question what
do you think the future holds for
central Africa that's a really difficult
question you know the Central African
Republic has been dealt a really
difficult hand by history and
unfortunately that's not going to change
anytime soon I do think that the kind of
war type violence that we've seen over
the past couple of years that is abating
and there have been you know there are a
number of different initiatives that are
being spearheaded by international
actors to try to build peace in the
country you know I have some skepticism
about the approach of a lot of them but
at this point the country has come to
quite a nadir and I I hope that that
means that the only way to go is up even
if that is a very slow and fitful
process right well hopefully that will
be the case thank you so much for being
here was my pleasure and enjoy chatting
your work sure for more information
about professor Lombard and her work
please visit our website at yale edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you